more on this no wonder that in a new
Gallup poll by the way actual Americans
point to immigration as the issue most
important to them right behind our
government so why aren't the activists
the politicians the majority of the
media listening to you here to debate
Tom Holman former acting director of ice
and a Fox News contributor and Lisa
Johnson Firth is a principal of
immigration of immigrants first and a
professor of law at Georgetown
University it's good to have you both
let's start with you professor I
understand that the there's a great
humanitarian story to be told here there
are thousands and thousands of people
and indeed millions probably in Central
America I've spent a lot of time in both
Salvador and Guatemala and I know the
people well I know the place well
beautiful countries very corrupt but
most of these aren't asylees most of
these are economic migrants and by the
own our own Border Patrol even during
Obama most of them are overwhelmingly
rejected so why isn't the metering
slowing this down so we can process
people in an orderly way why isn't that
the right way to go well first I would
take issue that they are economic
migrants if you read the State
Department report on any of these
countries the northern triangle there
are some of the most violent countries
in the world gangs have as you know that
taken over those countries are very
corrupt and very dangerous and so I
would say I've been practicing
immigration law for about 16 years ten
years ago yes I was seeing many more
economic migrants now I believe that I'm
seeing in my caseload true asylum
seekers fleeing horrific gang violence
but that's not really that's not one of
the credit that doesn't work on the
credible field cat fear cases are
difficult to win because the way Asylum
law has been constructed what do you
think it should be more it should be
more lenient than it is now I think that
first of all getting to the metering I'm
gonna address your your issue but
getting to the metering issue when we
are having people reports ports of entry
rather than being able to cross the
border wherever which is obviously being
challenged Trump's decision to have that
we're basically forcing a huge
population to go through very small
entry points and
the process of waiting those people are
subject to violence while they're
waiting I just interviewed a woman last
week who was raped while waiting at the
border she'd actually been gang-raped 60
times and her process of coming to the
United States and so I think we're
increasing the danger obviously some
people will turn back I think it is a
way that the government is discouraging
people from legitimately presenting
asylum claims at the board that they're
entitled to under US law and then
they're Tom I think the politicians have
really blown us I mean I have no doubt
that horrific things we already know
horrific things have happened to
children to women and to others and
there are criminal elements within the
migrant Caravan we know that that's
already been proven but politicians
refuse to do what they need to do to
make this system work they refuse it and
right now on Capitol the light's still
on over there they're not gonna do
anything but look the politicians as you
said it's a political ploy what they're
doing down there they went down they got
this group of 15 moved into the front
line I had the 25 other 2,500 people
that were waiting in line playing by the
rules I got this reviewed you I've been
enforced immigration a lot about twice
as long as you've been practicing it and
I'm telling you mostly people are not
legitimate side of seekers violence is
not a claim for for asylum in nine
ninety percent me lose it what the
politicians all be doing rather than
going out and pulling a political ploy
that they're doing they all be here in
Washington DC fixing the loopholes in
our immigration laws that causes these
caravans even exist in the first place
I've been up on hill many times this
past year with the secretary close if
you don't raise asylum bar no address
the floor is settlement agreement give
is detention money so it's not back to
catching release as they close these
loopholes they will stop a lot this
iliad immigration but it isn't about
protecting the border
it isn't about closing loopholes is
about taking on the Trump administration
is about politics had a public safety
national security I want to play
something this was Joe Scarborough this
morning who was a Republican I guess
there's no longer Republican he made
this comment let's watch I believe that
when you come to the United States you
should come here legally this is what is
lost in this argument these people
coming to America now are coming here
legally they are seeking refugee
status and and that is legal and as far
as America being overloaded there's a
net negative flow back into Mexico net
negative flow back into Mexico it's not
Mexico that's a point right it's as more
as the Central American as you say the
triangle of folks are the ones who are
coming in we guys take it back to the
basics and though they're not refugees
they're asylees he's totally Mex mixing
up the issue and starts talking about we
gotta get back to the regional issue if
they are really escaping fear and
persecution homeowners there in Mexico
all right they've already skipped that
fear in persecution and they ought to be
claiming asylum in the first safe place
that come to a couple of thousand people
already took Mexico up on that so it
isn't about escaping fear and
persecution this is about getting to
United States because maybe violence
because rejoined family members
illegally already here and I want the
professor react just looks like the
United States is going to give billions
of dollars to Mexico and the Central
America in part to try to help them keep
people in their homelands and also give
people jobs in Mexico I guess what is it
4.6 billion dollars they came out today
I guess that's it looks like they're not
gonna they're not given that money for
nothing that money is going I think in
part say look you got to stop this flow
coming up to the United States you got
to start incorporating people in New
Mexico why aren't the people staying in
Mexico because Mexico's not safe either
the same gangs and cartels that are in
Honduras and El Salvador and Guatemala
are also in Mexico I think everybody
from those countries should just be able
to come because it's a bad place because
there are a lot of bad places around I
would say that if you look at the
American history and our history in
Central America of what we've done over
the past 100 years that we have created
a lot of the refugee crisis it's kind of
a reparation thing I believe in part of
it is that yes we should be sending
money to those countries to help
establish Seifer government's more
accountable governments but it's also
that's not going to happen overnight and
in the meantime we do have thousands of
particularly of women and children who
are fleeing for their lives and that
must be addressed and we have an
international obligation to address that
international obligation Tom the facts
are the facts of
as that was a heist director we removed
thousands of people from Guatemala
Honduras and El Salvador to their
countries every day and there's no claim
of fear these planes are full several
planes a week put on all three of those
countries very few Mexicans claim asylum
so I don't agree with you know Mexico
not be in a safe place
we're not robbed Mexicans claim asylum
for four reasons so again we gotta get
back to the basics of what's going
really going on here these are people
want to come to this country for a
better life can't blame them for that
now
but you can't want to be a part of the
greatest country on Earth and not
respect us laws you can't have it both
ways
well skipping the line but they're also
using the system as it exists today the
system is is ridiculous and the fact
that this crowd up on Capitol Hill
will not address this tonight they
should be addressing this issue it is a
crisis crisis under Southern board has
been for a long time great debate you
guys thank you so much